he is the better half of the move the
sticks podcast
he is um which is uh must listen to
material where all podcasts are acquired
from the nfl media group here on the
rich eisen show fresh off of a mock
draft 3.0
uh bucky brooks here uh to help us kick
off our draft month coverage of the nfl
draft how are you doing bucky
rich what's going on how are you doing
so uh are you aware bucky uh you're a
3.0 that that um that uh for some reason
uh daniel has a 3.1 out is that a topper
is that he's just trying to top you here
bucky on the mic draft what's going on
with that i mean we're
we're always competing and so i don't
understand the difference between
mine being designated 3.0 and his being
designated 3.1
i have to get with him on the next
podcast kind of figure out what that is
yeah i do i've never heard of that i've
never heard of the the the the number
to the right of the decimal moving in
the mock draft world
i would definitely bring that up to him
on the next move the sticks podcast um
i definitely will maybe maybe have
something to do with like all the
maneuvering that we've seen with trade
and maybe because it might have been
right after deshaun washington goes and
the movement with the jackson so he did
a quick
a amendment to kind of figure out how to
get another po
rap out there right i don't know i have
to figure that out all right i don't
mean look you guys do such a great job i
don't want to cause any dissension even
though i guess i just did
okay let's let's jump into this here uh
with your mock draft i i would be as a
jet fan so thrilled
so thrilled they go and get sauce
gardner at four and kyle hamilton at ten
how how how real do you think that is i
would sign for that literally right now
bucky brooks oh well
i mean look i think this is for the jets
i think it's a realistic possibility for
them to do it one you have to understand
the links and the ties robert sala uh
spent time with the seattle seahawks he
saw what the impact the legion of boom
had on that team and so what most
coaches do is when they go somewhere
they try and recreate their previous
destination and what they had and so in
sauce gardner you have a guy with the
length and the size that um
jet fans will think of antonio cromartie
probably may see a richard sherman type
guy because the length will allow him to
stymie while he receives the line of
scrimmage he is an outstanding
competitor he's a guy who has all the
tools on the toolbox that you look for
on the perimeter he tackles he is a guy
that is
really wired the right way so i think
new york won't overwhelm him this is a
guy that just loves ball and everything
in his background suggested he's gonna
be an a1 player because he's committed
and kyle hamilton what you're doing is
you're having a blend a little mix of
the cam chancellor physicality and
toughness middle line of scrimmage a guy
who absolutely destroys runnings running
back in the hole but then he is
different because you don't see guys
that have six four 220 pounds who have
the ball skills that he possesses and so
he's the guy that can play in the box
and he's just
um comfortable playing in the deep
middle and so if you're a robinson you
got a chance to get both of those guys
at the top 10 to really fortify a
secondary that should be a new and
improved defense i think you feel good
about handling the cars of those guys
and how fitting or ironic it would be
that to to i guess replicate as you
point out a legion of boom type of
defense that they use a draft choice
from seattle that they got in a jamal
adams trade in order to actually
pull off that double dip that would be
quite something um
kayvon thibodeaux is third in your list
to the texans and dj daniel jeremiah
your move the sticks com padre had the
same thing what was your take on
thibodeau's combine
um and you now combine it with um pro
day material
what do you make of of the evaluation
coming out of the kanban and and him
still being now third on
your and uh dj's mock draft list
so i would say that kayvon typical is
one of the more talented prospects in
the draft class but he's also one of the
more polarized and the reason he's
polarizing is because on the field what
you see is a guy who's a flasher
stepping onto the scene as a freshman he
goes to this nine tax right away at
oregon he is dominant off the edge he
has seven fourth quarter fact that
freshman season but then we never quite
saw
a level of dominance where he stacked on
top of it um so you have that where it
kind of leaves you wanting more and then
look he's a big brand he was the number
one overall recruit when he came out of
the class he's a guy who's done these
phenomenal deals off the field and so
fairly and fair or not some people kind
of judge him but wonder if he focused
enough on the game that said the guy is
super talented and in a league that is
built on pastors and past rushers he's
one of the best in the game and in the
right system with the right coach this
guy could be a superstar in the position
so you think he's going to go third and
trayvon walker second to the lions he
looked so good at the combine trayvon
walker he's so good
yeah he is and so like here's the thing
[ __ ] about trayvon walker um
i wasn't really as high on him early
because i'm like man i see the
athleticism i see the guy do a bunch of
different things but the production
doesn't necessarily match the potential
but then when you get around a bunch of
e-line coaches in the league
they are just absolutely captivated and
spent with this guy's athleticism his
movement skills the explosiveness and
what he does and so then when opposed to
them are you worried about the
production and where do you play him
they're like no because like the stuff
that he had you can't coach now it's
about putting him in the position where
he can maximize his talent by chasing
the past and getting out there and going
hard and doing those other things and
they were like don't judge him on the
production
based on who was around him because
remember jordan davis said great walker
and uh nicole dean and all these other
first rounders and top picks from
georgia we're all on the same defense so
look there's only one ball to shape
there's only one play that can be made
on a given down so don't tell them on
the production but when you look at the
tape he does pop and that's why he's in
conversation not only it too
he certainly could be a reality at
number one for the jacksonville jaguar
which would leave hutchinson to stay put
in the state of michigan and bucky
brooks you the way you have it all
mocked out right now the giants would
have their choice of offensive lineman
that that's that's exactly what when
they hit their knees at night
over the next several weeks is that is
that is that what they're looking for
with the giants in their front office
right now well yeah well absolutely if
you go back like they think of the name
the giants and going all the way back
from georgia the reason the giants uh
have always had a preference for big
guys is because they are the giants they
believe that the game is played up front
in the trenches uh you need bigger
better bodies up front to be able to win
games consistently knowing joe shane
because we work together in carolina
he's a guy who loves prototypes he wants
to get big physical guys at the point of
attack that can mold people and bash so
you can run the football when you need
to run it but you also can protect the
quarterback and so when looking at the
draft class you have evan neil from
alabama was probably the more refined
technically sound of the guys in that
box and then you have nikki ekwanu who's
just a freak athlete who is nasty who
kind of changes the tenor of the room
when he's when he when he shows up
because he is kind of the nightclub
bouncer that throws guys out for being
unruly
and so when you see him just throw guys
on the field
it kind of catches your attention so one
of those guys can't be the character of
the giant and i don't think they could
go wrong with either one bucky brooks
here on the rich eisen show um we've
reached the draft month and um and we're
moving down bucky's mock draft here on
the rich eisen show rank the wide
receivers how do you see the wide
receiver group it's so deep they look so
terrific at the combine you know you got
you got um teams like the packers and
now the chiefs having lost or traded
away their top whiteouts they're now
in the business of adding some big-time
talent walk me through how you see the
wide receiver group in this draft bucky
the wide receiver group is really
interesting because it comes down to
play right it's like going to the ice
cube shop and trying to determine what
flavor do you want on a given night and
so do you want the big body play maker
like a a drake london who can absolutely
dominate and crush it on the outside
because he can land 50 50 balls and then
you have jaylon burns who also kind of
sets the field as that big body
playmaker and then you have these little
scooters right these fast guys that can
make plays whether it's gary wilson or
chris olavey you have guys down the
ranks and skye moore you have a another
playmaker um
in david bill not quite in that case but
castle can just kind of make plays and
so you have to figure out what you want
but i think about those two teams the
green bay packers and the kansas city
chiefs part of the reason why teams are
more comfortable letting these elite
wide receivers go because we've seen
these young guys come in and have
immediate success and so i believe out
of that crew that we talk about we may
not have the jamar chase type where you
can see him going in the top five and
they're immediately going to pop but
these guys in the bottom of the first
round they are intriguing because they
are right now ready plug and play put
them in they can make big plays and i
think you can see a lot of these guys uh
come back up in conversation when we
talk about pro bowl kids and nominees as
first year players because they don't
have opportunities to be in a major
state and make plays by the way well i
mean on your mock here bucky the fact
that you you think this and if this
happens
that the chiefs get skye moore from
western michigan you know tyreek out
skymorin obviously there's a large
amount of shoes to fill with the cheetah
but i saw this kid work out i heard what
dj said about him and other uh
evaluators like yourself that would be
huge that would that would be a that
would be tremendous if that kid winds up
in kansas city
by the way
interviews tremendous because you have
to think about this there's been a lot
of conversation about tyreek hill and
you know him being one-on-one and he is
a player but you have to understand when
the kansas city chiefs drafted him they
got them in the fifth round pick he was
a punt retainer he was a former running
back coming out of oklahoma oklahoma
state and going to another destination
before you get to kansas city
no one knew that he was going to be a
number one receiver right so andy lee
and those guys have the confidence in
knowing that not necessarily that they
created tyre retail but they discovered
and developed and nurtured that kind of
talent so they feel like they can go
back in the draft and a draft is
increasingly producing more talented
wide receivers that can step up to play
they're confident that they can find a
player that won't necessarily replicate
that production but will give them a
more balanced wide receiver court
because you have to remember pat my home
struggles a lot of times were attributed
to the sandlot play that he and tabrik
hill had developed well now pat mahomes
will probably play a little more
discipline and detail from the pocket
and then you need raw runners guys
that's dependable and reliable in terms
of getting to their spots if they find
guys that can do that and scout boys one
of those guys that can do it i don't
think you will see any dropball from the
kansas city chiefs office all right last
one on your mock and then one more
question before i send you on your your
friday bucky brooks my colleague from
the nfl media group and move the stixx
podcast um you're i'm very proud of
myself i didn't bring up quarterbacks to
the very end here um your your mock
draft zero quarterbacks in the first
round simple question what's up with
that
uh what's amazing is this like from you
and dj i heard you guys when i was doing
the coverage on the field you guys were
waxing poetic about the impressive
combined performances of all the
quarterbacks and then you know what
happened rich on monday we got on the
plane and then there was a series of
dominoes where every quarterback in the
league was traded well to wilson
and roger's gun
let's go and on and on and on and so my
immediate reaction to that is as high as
we might have been on the quarterbacks
and how they perform the league got a
chance to look at those guys up close
and personal and maybe they don't have
the same opinion of those guys and it
also is altered and impacted by the fact
that when we looked at the postseason
and we saw josh allen and pat mahomes
and joe burrow and we know that justin
herbert is out there you now are not
only comparing the quarterbacks in the
2022 class against each other you're
looking at them compared to josh allen
pat mahomes justin herbert joe burrow
and the superhero powers that they have
and if you don't deem the player or
prospect that you're thinking about in
the first round to being able to match
up with those guys in the shootout you
better serve to move on and wait for
another guy to come because you know
that in the end the tournament is
determined by the best quarterbacks and
i don't know if these quarterbacks have
the superpowers of some of those other
quarterbacks that are in the league that
are 25 and up so then which one that
doesn't go in the first round let's say
you this this actually happens um who
does have the best chance to be
russell or dak or you know that third
for even you know derek carr second
third fourth round picks who have
terrific careers and and uh super bowl
possibilities in them i'll say desert is
the one to keep your eye out
the kid from cincinnati is interesting
he has 44 career wins you saw the
performance that he put up at the
combine in terms of his athleticism 4-4
speed 35 is vertical which speaks to his
explosiveness but is the way that he
managed at our advance in cincinnati but
getting this team a group of team to
play in the playoffs and winning games
and doing all that speaks volumes and so
we look at the quarterbacks that do the
deck prescott kind of thing they kind of
do their stuff in cosmo and dak prescott
took mississippi state and made them the
number one team fourth stretch there
during this time i think desmond ritter
is the quarterback to keep your eye on
because to be
his experience
and his overall explosiveness will give
him a chance to be a really successful
personally how about that all right uh
bucky brooks look um
last thing here uh you're a humble man
anybody can hear that in your voice um
you don't you don't say things with your
chest you don't puff your chest out
you're you're you're even keel that said
um come saturday night if your tar heels
beat duke how impossible will you be to
deal with that give everyone a little
idea of what tar heel nation would be
like if they send coach k packing
for good ol
taste of it when retards went into
cameron right and sent coach k out with
an l i would think that we would be
unsolvable if we have an opportunity to
officially end it and so the difference
is though like if you win the semifinals
you have to cap it off the right way
sure because it just wouldn't look
been a long time tario uh fan since both
like championships are kind of like the
standard but this
would have a little extra sweetness if
we can kind of send duke and everyone
packing in the final four like it's a
big deal you know how that thing is kind
of like the big game with you guys in
ohio state but this thing here on
saturday night oh that's going to be
after get my targets pulled up oh i
honestly like you can't script it right
i mean it's
it's one of the greatest rivalries in
anything
and it's the first time they faced each
other in in a win or go home ncaa
tournament and it's co it's the final
four and it's it it would be to end
coach k's career like that would be it
you
you
it would change you
you couldn't get any smack talk from a
duke fan the rest of planet earth
existing right i mean
no like this this would be
look it would be beyond belief and i've
been there i've like i've been at games
when duke has won carolina's two and
vice versa but this is different because
like it's feeling that canon is this
major underdog and right and everyone
views duke as the evil empire and my
carolina right now i guess it's gonna be
the little engine that could but in
their minds because they're eight miles
away because they say pick a ball
against each other all the time
carolina doesn't do duke like that and
so because of that there's like
disrespect but this inner
competitiveness and hatred that these
teams have for one another oh it's gonna
be
i mean it's gonna be a game that
i hope my guys show up and hope we play
well but this this is gonna have the
makers of being a classic and we get a
chance to get the throttle forward uh
where are you watching it what's your
plan tomorrow night
uh i think because i don't want to be
around the people i think i need to
scream at the career but i think this
might have to be a little home feeling
to be able to do it i don't know it's
tough this guy's like this this one this
one is a lot it's a lot of rich
survivors to watch well you heard the
the uh
country music star eric church
canceled this concert to go to to go to
the game to watch targets did you hear
that you heard that's right yes yes
yes i saw that like rich the infinity
that we have for carolina is much like
the way that you feel to your wolverines
no you shut it down
when the target is on you shut it down
i understood that he was like let it be
darn i am going to watch the target and
before and just so you remember it's the
superdome and then when the target is in
the superdome everyone goes back to the
shot because that's when mike became
michael in 82. so we can talk about the
coach k saying but as a kid i remember
michael jordan hit the shot and so my
expectation that sawyers are going to
run that back all over you
look man i i also know whenever michigan
played ohio state and again the stakes
are
are huge obviously but
this is a totally different uh
stratosphere i always have a couple of
ohio state guys who i know or or gauze
or i'm going to text first you have a
dookie in mind that you would text
of go about it like i think i learned a
long time ago for party shot now when
you said look
when you win you say nothing you don't
have to say this because everyone knows
you're wearing so that's the expectation
i expect to like pop on twitter late at
night like first time
start thinking
i will be thinking of you sir thank you
for the time here let's do this uh a
couple of times at least before the
draft and i appreciate the time today
thanks bucky all right i really
appreciate it you guys bucky brooks
everybody
he's a tar heel through and through how
to how to go out the door with that when
you win everyone knows
oh it's on
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here